hi welcome to my presentation my name is
kim hee i'm a phd candidate at hyderabad
university hospital in manhattan
so um today
i'm going to talk about really
password deep learning everybody talks
about deep learning and i want to add a
couple of more password
efficiency and pruning and quantization
so um
well
so it's part of my working paper i'm
currently
making many experiments and some of the
results i want to bring it today and
share with you and i want to learn
something
out of the experiment with you i try to
make this talk less technical it's very
technical talk um but i
i try to make it more entertaining so um
before i start my talk i want to talk a
little bit about my library tree
institute i am affiliated
um so my laboratory we are kind of
software development company and at the
same time we are doing research so my
daily work i am implementing
infrastructure for the hospital we are
building up data integration center with
using
open source tool like shown on the
symbol on on here
this is because we have to make data
integration center in germany as a
part of
medical informatics initiative
by government
and there are four consortium we are a
partner of one consortium called mirakum
is highlighted
in blue color
we are the largest one and i think we
are the coolest one because we are only
using open source two we are not buying
third party party solution
just for your information
data and hospital there a lot is shown
on the um
right bottom corner
they're
like hierarchical structure and they're
all different sort of data i just want
to give you some impressions there are
complex hierarchical and has time time
stamps and it's kind of growing over
time
so when i joined my laboratory my
professor gave me a mission for my phd
topic do something
for infectious disease it's desperately
desperately general isn't it so i was a
bit
confused i don't know what to do and i
read
many papers working on this field about
infectious disease
and i wanted to kind of find some
studies
to make the things automated and make it
faster and then i come up with a paper
which is
written here published in 2018 by people
from harvard
they make the gram stain image analysis
they make it automated
they made
it pretty good
which highlighted in a red box
so sensitive
sensitivity and specificity
it's
higher than 95 percent except one so
there they make quite a good solution
but
but um
[Music]
to
make a um classification of one image
takes about nine minutes which is to me
it's nonsense i mean human can do it
faster even though image is pretty big
it's about one gigabyte of image for one
single image like you see the the pixel
over there
but it's too slow so i find this would
be my
topic for my phd so i
this led me to this topic today
um so but i'm not the only one who finds
out this challenge there are a lot of
people researchers and big id
corporation they're working on
make deep learning training and
influence faster
without losing more their performances
and then i find this graph
is quite um
it's showing what's going on in this
field
this graph is made by professor han from
mit university
and um first of all i want to highlight
that there are two um kind of solutions
to tackle this problem so one is about
algorithm
side so mathematically you want to take
this problem to make it faster another
one hardware innovation to make the
processing faster and also i want to
make a distinction
uh what to make it fast do you want to
make it
do you want to make training faster or
do you want to make inference faster so
um there are two different distinctions
and today we only cover on the uh left
up corner
we want to make inference time faster
mathematical solution with mathematical
solution
one is about pruning another one is
quantization
so
i think
i'm not sure
please raise your hands is there anyone
who work on deep learning
projects before
good and have you ever applied this
technique pruning or quantization how
nice
great so maybe we can be good friends
so about the first impression because
most of people you don't really um
know about heard of this terminology so
let's clarify a little bit
um so about quantification oh sorry
quantization
um it's i think this is a quite good
motivating example so
instead of
many decimal number
you just want to use in integer number
two for the processing and this is this
is good enough and sometimes it makes
the uh performance even better i will
gonna prove it later on uh following
slide and it reduce quite a lot of bits
so usual computation you need 32 bits
for floating number but with integer
quantization you need just eight bits
which you know you see that four times
minimum four times you save the
memory space
and about pruning it's more
intuitive
there are lots of you know connection
between neurons to the layers
and
most of them they're not so significant
so
the parameter i'm talking about because
it's like linear algebra between neuron
to neuron
and um if
it's not so significant you can just rid
of it and it doesn't really harm the
performance so that's about pruning and
quantization
and uh why does talk matter to you um
well i would say if unless you're going
to retire within five or ten ten years
this deep learning
you have to deal with it you cannot
avoid it and also
um
the graph on the right upper corner this
is um the energy consumption
uh at facebook data center and it's
doubling every year and you you know
that the association between uh global
warming and energy consumption and
that's really matter to
to us and also next generation
and also
number of iot devices it's also called
edge devices it's increasing
quite rapidly
and i have checked the specification of
google glass
and it's not really powerful as computer
user computer you have so google glass
consists of two gigabytes of memories
and 12 gigabytes of storage usable
storage size which is not really big so
you have to compress the model
to deploy the solution on such a small
device
this is
what's happening
behind
for the quantization well pruning is
easy you just rid of like
not really significant parameter within
biases uh quantization it's more complex
i don't want to go into uh detail but
that's what's going on you kind of
quantize not every single computation
but some of them and then you um add
adder you don't really use integer but
there you use
um 32-bit but i don't want to go in
detail but that's what's going on behind
and this is happening just for one
single neuron and you can imagine there
are thousands of neurons for the deep
learning
network
and in order to prune and quantize your
model you have to have a model right and
i don't want to i didn't want to build
up my own model because there are
already many great
solutions
openly accessible
maybe you have heard of inception and
resnet and mobile those trees are quite
popular model and i uh just download it
and then i
fine tune to to my image dataset which
you have seen in the beginning graeme
stein images which is uh current
positive or graph negative so fairly
straightforward and simple uh the image
i'm using and then i didn't want to pick
up the fine tuning parameter randomly no
i didn't follow my intuition so i made
like 10 times of experiment of each of
the hyperparameters and then pick up the
highest average performance to to
further prune and quantize just for your
information i didn't pick up the render
on the model randomly
and then uh finally we end up to
the first results correct
so it's really tiny
that
point highlighted in red color it's
outcome of inception model
blue one it's model of resnet
purple on the left side it's a mobilenet
model uh performance
and x-axis is the size of the model and
then uh y-axis is accuracy so you can
see like some of the mobile net it's
super tiny like three megabytes uh you
you don't have good performance which
i'm going to address it later but
like uh those on the left upper corner
even less than
10 megabytes of motor size you do fairly
good um you make fairly good uh outcome
about 90 percent of accuracy
well also what we can learn from this
graph
inception
outperform compared to other models
on my problem i don't want to say
inception is better than
other model for general problem but
you have to therefore empirically make
experiment
maybe resonate is
better
it's better for other problems like
detection object detection or
other image input so in particularly my
problem inception perform better
and also i see some fluctuation more
fluctuation on the mobile net which is
um
quite interesting i found i wanted to go
more digging into
particularly those uh the one on the
left bottom corner
which
has quite high sparsity so i rid of 90
of the connection the parameter
and it's kind of make random guessing 55
percent of accuracy is really random
guessing
and um i wanted to
analyze more why it behaves such and how
can i improve it
and i got inspiration from this study
uh from stanford university and at l
they
also end up first really low accuracy
or
a bit complicated
problem compared to mine i'm i'm
classifying just to type positive or
negative but this guy using imagenet
dataset has
1 thousands of classes so it's a bit
complex than mine
but
what they did
they
trained really really long so basically
here on the x-axis you see like
scientific notation e to the power of
five
so if they train
60
thousands of apples
epoch is uh one cycle you go through
whole training data set
and then it recovers the accuracy so
that was kind of inspiration to me so
let's train longer to the mobile net
with ninety percent of sparsity
and uh
beforehand i stopped at one hundred of
efforts and i trained five thousands of
times of um
for the training and then it really um
kind of
performing better and better
it took
about two days because my laboratory has
quite powerful gpu
tesla porta this cost
more than 20 thousands of euro one gpu
so it's expensive than small car
um so it's a two days but
with normal computer i think it will
take really many many days maybe a month
and um right so that's i found quite
interesting maybe with ten thousands of
apple longer training i think i would
end off to ninety percent of accuracy
so uh some results of quantization i
didn't have all the results which i was
expecting therefore some columns are
empty which i'm going to collect it next
coming week
what we can learn from here so
i only
showing you the results of um
well one model mobile net model with
different sparsity rate ratio so 50
i read off parameter and zero percent
meaning i didn't read up any parameter
so it's kind of um acting as a baseline
model
what we can learn from here i find it's
interesting
well
reducing
number of bit it really doesn't harm at
all sometimes it even uh perform better
especially here like eight ins it
performs better than 32 slots
with zero sparsity ratio
but uh the compression ratio compared to
the given model it's quite impressive
second
what we can learn
combination of pruning and
quantization that leads you better
results i i learned
so those on the first upper fourth
result accuracy you see generally
perform one or two percent better than
um no pruning technique
and
well latency
i observed that i tested with
the computer server with powerful gpu
but it doesn't really give me
it doesn't really reduce the time and i
wonder why it happened i expect to have
much less time to execute this
classification
but i
noticed that
this quantization
is converting um the
computation based on different up
well hardware operation so
i was training i trained the model with
cpu uh 86
based cpu
and after conversion it works only good
for the arm based cpu which
which is
even used on mobile phone and also smart
devices so it didn't really perform
good on the powerful server so i need to
kind of
work on it to test correctly
so
that's it take away
from my talk
uh
maybe you can remember to keyword
pruning and quantization
that
gives you good outcome
and also it reduce
the motor size dramatically
right this is i think the most important
message you can take away
so if you have any questions
maybe we don't have enough time maybe
later on we can talk you can chat thank
you
thank you very much